- [Girl] Oh, he did it.
Oh, my.
- These are some people of the internet,
wearing a Meta Quest 2 headset
and playing Richie's Plank Experience.
A game where you jump off a virtual plank,
sometimes using a real plank
to make it seem more real.
This is me playing the same game.
There we go.
But unlike those others, I used a trick,
so I could avoid a similar feint.
Let me do a quick pass through check.
All right.
Okay, so you bought one of
these, the Oculus Quest Two.
The quest two, wait, the
Oculus, the Meta Quests Two,
that's it.
The meta quests two.
Then you realize this thing is really fun
but also pretty flawed and
hard to figure out sometimes.
Mom, is it you?
Luckily there are some hidden settings
and things you can buy that can help
with some of those issues.
Here are eight tips for making
the Quest work better for you.
Strap in everyone.
Number one, reset your direction.
Sometimes you don't wanna
keep spinning around like this
to find the main menu or
center spot in a gamer app.
So reset your view.
Look straight ahead in the
direction you want your main menu
or center of your app to appear
then press and hold the Oculus
button on right controller.
You'll see the Oculus logo appear.
Once the ring reaches all away around.
The virtual world will
snap to your new center.
Number two, double tap to pass through.
I want you to remember this,
furniture is the enemy of VR.
That's why you should enable pass through,
a feature that gives you a camera view,
albeit in black and white
of your real surroundings
without taking your headset
off, go to quick settings,
then settings and select guardian.
Toggle on double tap for
pass through shortcut.
Now tap your finger
twice on either the left
or right side of the headset.
And you'll instantly see the real world.
Number three, take screenshots.
Sure, in whatever app you're in,
you can back out to this menu here
and click take photo, but that's annoying.
Instead on your controller,
just hold down the Oculus button
and then hit the trigger.
You'll easily be able to snap screenshots.
Sadly, there's no button combo
for video screen recordings
like these, which brings
us to number four,
enable voice commands, go to settings.
Then system, then voice commands,
enable in-app voice commands.
And then the controller shortcut.
Now you can double-press
on the Oculus button
and the mic will start
listening for a command.
What time is it?
- [Oculus] It's 10:44 at night.
- What's the weather?
- [Oculus] Right now in Jersey
city, it's clear and 32.
- You can also go to settings,
experimental features
and enable, Hey Facebook.
Then you can just use the wake
phrase to give your command.
Hey, Facebook, launch Beat Saber.
(music plays)
Number five, turn on phone notifications.
This is not fun.
So instead, get your
phone notifications sent
to your headset.
Pair your headset to the Oculus app
on your phone.
In the app, go to menu and then devices,
then phone notifications,
and then toggle it on.
You can customize what phone
notifications now get delivered
to your headset.
Number six, strap a battery to your head,
an hour or two of playing a game
or wandering around in some virtual space.
And you'll see the
battery get into the red.
Getting battery low,
but not if you wear one of these,
yes, that's a battery patch strapped
to the back of my head.
This is the Kiwi Power Bang Fixing Strap.
For $35, you get a short power cable
and this strap which has
space for a battery pack.
You have to BYOB, bring your own battery
or you can charge your phone this way.
It's very cool.
If you wanna go higher end
and I kind of suggest you do.
Get Meta's own $109 Elite Strap,
battery inside here.
Number seven, make your
controllers rechargeable.
Sadly, the Quest two controllers
require AA batteries.
You could, of course buy
rechargeable, AA batteries.
Or you could go for Anker's
$99 fancy charging station
which has its own rechargeable batteries
and these special covers.
So you can just dock them to charge.
Number eight, use your hands.
You know what they say?
Your hands are your best controllers.
Actually, nobody says that
but really using your
hands can be very handy
when you wanna do something quickly
and you don't wanna
fumble for the controller,
go to settings then hands
and controllers, toggle on hand-tracking.
There are a few gestures to master,
to select something, pinch,
to scroll, move your pinch
in the direction you wanna go.
I can look at my hands pinch here.
It gets to some quick settings, like
It can be a bit janky, but when it works,
it's pretty cool and don't worry.
You can easily switch
between hand and controllers.
The system just picks up the right input.
All right, go live the dream
and strap a bunch of electronics
and a big battery to your head.
I'm sure that is very good for all of us.
I love my family. I love everybody.
Thank you for watching this video.